let me go next to Mike from Boston Mike
from Boston we haven't heard from for
for a little while I guess what's going
on with you Mike hi David thanks for
taking my call
pleasure huh you know I just want to
respond to this and kind of get your
view on it a couple callers ago I'm
really getting sick of these delusional
people out there and some of the people
on other progressives podcasts and blogs
people you know like crystal ball on on
rising and I know he's your friend Kyle
Kerensky on secular talk who are just so
anti Joe Biden and they seem to be out
for blood for him and I really can't
understand why if this crisis right now
that we are going through it does not
signal to people that chump must be
removed at all costs right you are not
only irresponsible you are borderline
selfish and not caring about the lives
that are being lost so let's take that I
babies let me let's take that piece by
piece Mike so first of all I have no
idea what crystal and Kyle have been
saying a big again I just I just don't
watch shows I work on my show you know
12 hours a day and then I relax with
some stuff that's not political content
but so let's let's go through it in
pieces first of all remove Trump at all
costs not if you're going to replace him
with something worse right so like I've
made the calculation that Biden is
better than Trump that's why I am going
to vote for Joe Biden to replace Trump
if you give me an option that's worse
than Trump then I say keep Trump because
I want to do harm reduction that part
probably we agree on right well yeah I
mean but the only real I agree at this
point in time were these are the options
it's Joe Biden or or it's Donald Trump
now right why would crystal I'm taking
your word that crystal and Kyle are very
much anti Trump as you point out my
guess is if you ask them why they would
say that it's because maybe they don't
see Biden is better than Trump or they
see Biden being elected as a path
- something that doesn't fix the problem
in the longer term I'd have to ask them
right I mean you're asking me about
stuff I haven't seen my guess is if you
ask them they they would have a
different perspective about and they
would be able to articulate why they are
as anti by de Nazz you describe them to
be I've made my view clear which is when
I look at history I don't see
acceleration Astari having worked and
acceleration is perspectives as having
worked I see we have succeeded through
getting people in power who will make
responsible choices to the Supreme Court
which will then uphold the improvements
that are made by the people that we
elect that that's what I've seen in the
Progressive Era the New Deal era and the
civil rights era so that's how I have
established my framework and I think
what you're pointing to is somebody who
has a different framework I would say so
yes I mean but I just don't get the
point I mean I think I don't think I
look at that I look at the landscape in
the country
the way that this crisis is being
handled the way that the last three and
a half years has gone and I don't I
don't think this country can handle
another four years of Donald Trump by
anyone I agree with you I'm not happen
to agree with you I mean listen my so
everybody has to figure out what works
for them as I said before somebody
doesn't want to vote Biden because they
actually believe the country is better
off with Biden losing and Trump getting
four more years then they shouldn't vote
Biden right but I just I want everybody
to be clear and there's there's a
contingent that I'm seeing not Kyl and
crystal but stuff like I'll look at my
subreddit each day and I'll look at my
Twitter mentions each day where there
are people who are doing an anti by Dan
thing but they're not actually saying
they think Trump is better so then it's
like well what are you just posturing or
are you trying to get a certain reaction
are you trying to get Joe to come beg
for your vote or whatnot like I don't
need any of that stuff I'm plenty busy
I'm just like buy whatever I'm going for
Biden they're mad that they didn't get
their guy in their diverse Bernie
I was at Bernie Sanders guy okay and I
understand the disappointment yeah but
you know sometimes when there's no great
choice and there's no right answer you
do what you gotta do and take the best
option available to you this is Andre
that's my perspective and you know what
I think is important to do is I don't
see any benefit in going around and
attacking the motives of Cristal and
Kyle like again I'm going by what you're
telling me but if they've come to the
conclusion that they're never voting
Biden and I'm not saying that that's
what they're I don't know if that's what
they're doing but if they did my
instinct is to assume again because I
know them to some degree I assume that
they've come to that conclusion through
some different framework than I have
rather than they don't care about death
like you said I mean clearly they both
care about death I know them well enough
to know they care about people dying I'm
guessing they're working with a
different framework right I guess my
point is is that I guess what I'm trying
to say is that if in my in my opinion in
my view if you really care about the
well-being of this country you know and
you were a Bernie Sanders supporter or
an Elizabeth Warren supporter and you
know you're looking at this election and
you're just gonna say well you know what
if I couldn't just get my guy and if we
can't have it all or nothing right now
right I don't really care what happens
to the country I'm gonna vote third
party or not vote at all or and do
whatever I think you're I think you're
extremely off-base and extremely selfish
and not really caring about a lot of the
suffering that's going on with some of
these people right now
yes I'm like it's not your frustration
is that there are people who are coming
to different conclusions than you and
you're frustrated by that because for
you the the the conclusion you've come
to is so obvious right I mean look I was
gonna vote for whoever the Democratic
nominee was that's just how I went into
this whole you know election cycle which
we're going because I've seen what
happens when you make your responsible
choices and I just think they're being
irresponsible
all right Mike from Boston great to hear
from you let's see if we can check in
with our caller from the 6-1-6 area code
who is calling today from
six one six I think that's me
yes it is anyway yeah hi David thank the
trees I'm a number this is Justin from
Michigan hey John the west side it's a
bit more of a technical question here
but just to jump right in
I don't recall you commenting on the
israeli-palestinian deal of the century
quote-unquote opposed by Trump which was
largely drafted by Jared Kushner so if
you've seen a suppose map the potential
Palestinian state looks like scattered
islands more or less within the Negev
desert and as you probably heard gansan
Netanyahu just recently signed an
agreement to essentially Anna Clark laws
at the West Bank seeming in tandem with
this plan you know just to complete it
for the 2020 election and just sort of
part this is speculative here but it
also just sort of sweep it under the rug
during the corona virus pandemic so my
question is what do you think of the
plan is it in any way feasible and isn't
it sort of a slap in the face to
Palestinian aspirations of a statehood
along the 1967 borders
I know it's loaded but hey here's some
foreign policy for you so is this by
this one you say that this is the deal
from about a year ago right that's right
yeah so I I did I did comment on it at
the time and did one or two a pretty
detailed clips about it I don't have the
map in front of me but certainly I've
spoken before about the importance of
you know having a contiguous Palestinian
state my you know without having all of
the details refreshed right in front of
me I wouldn't be able to say anything
more than what I said a year ago or
whenever when when I covered it although
what I will restate is I simply do not
believe that the arbiters to a long
lasting deal in the israeli-palestinian
conflict are going to be Benjamin
Netanyahu nor any deal in which Hamas is
involved that I've been saying that for
years I maintain that that is the case
that that will not be the case that that
won't work and beyond that you know Mike
I haven't looked at the deal for a year
and you know I would check out my prior
commentary
mm-hmm kena follow that up quickly
sure so with so would you then argue
that any plan should begin with the
Palestinian Authority which would then
be widely embraced by the Palestinian
people in Gaza which would then you know
in turn I don't know where they keep the
a domino effect with Hamas leadership I
eat well what I would love to see first
would be Hamas removed from power period
before we have to have this domino
effect and and again that hummus has a
stranglehold in Gaza and I don't know
that I see that happening anytime soon
either mm-hmm right absolutely well hey
I'll definitely check out those clips
thank you so much for your response and
yeah I'll be calling it at some point
with with with perhaps a few different
questions for you about foreign policy
but thank you so much thank you so much
appreciate the phone call great to hear
from you I as always apologize to
everybody I was not able to get to but
we will take calls again we'll go to a
quick break and be back with your
questions after this